they're two stars out there while harden
takes a break
this could be a dangerous time for the
rockets
lakers might have missed a lob there
with davis
going to the basket now he's got it shot
clock at four davis of fleuria moves
rondo got to put one up
and rondo for three big shot for
region rondo when lebron james is
playing the way he has played how do you
slow him down
well you don't you gotta make sure you
get all the 50 50 balls do all the
little things
and then hopefully
all right and thanks to jared greenberg
lakers scoring
off a turnover to start this quarter
their first points off a turnover
tonight as lebron james
gets it he's got 12 tonight james gets
it deep
scores over gordon
rondo he'll pull a three and rondo hits
another one
largest laker lead tonight look at that
laker bench that coaching staff on their
feet
here's lebron gives it up morris across
court rondo just hit a three
and rondo has got his third made three
of the night
breakers don't have a third guy rajon
rondo
is saying yes we do and it's me and they
double team harden and get a steal
and another rondo buckers don't have a
third guy
rajon rondo is saying yes we do
and it's me and they double team harden
and get a steal
and another rondo bucket that's a 10-0
laker run rondo has the last eight
points for the lakers
mark keith gives it right back to him
now it's caruso and he buries a three
and the lakers got the foot on the gas
here in the fourth quarter it's a ten
point lead
well rajon rondo is scoring 17 points
but he's also making plays like that to
alex caruso defense off the ball has
been
active was tied at 82 at the end of the
third
and make it a 17-5 run
and leads to the bucket at the other end
he just faces
up jeff green jab step rockets would
rather live with markief morris shooting
the three than anthony davis in the post
nice pick by caruso knocked it out of
the hands in transition rondo
19 for rondo but the lakers in control
here as we approach the one-minute mark
rondo has been spectacular
and a nice lead for kuzma kuzma has been
great off the ball